eu não conheci meu pai biológico
a minha mãe ela fez amor com alguém e
depois nunca mais me contou
quero ficar com a criança ou jovem que
começa a criar né
não existe star wars e acha que o lux
country que em algum momento da verdade
vader de levar pro lado do lado negro da
força
e eu fiquei pensando humano que ensina
que o meu pai meu primo começar com uma
história que meu pai era um mergulhador
aventureiro que morreu antes de eu
nascer e aí eu descobri que a minha mãe
da amiga do falcão do inter
e aí eu disse meu é meu pai meu pai o
falcão o inter vem e um dia você
afilhado da cristina ranzolin
e aí depois eu fiquei pensando pô eu
podia ser filho do ex batista né
não agora mas na época ele era mega rico
eu pensei cara
este podia ser o meu pai esse cara podia
aparecer do nada e dizer 'eu jesus o seu
pai e agora você pirou nário eu já é
papai te amo em março deste ano março de
2015 minha mãe descobriu um câncer no
útero e decidiu contar que meu pai eo
meu pai não é um artista
meu pai só o cargo
eu sou um cara a cara com quem ela se
relacionou engravidou
assim e essa história mais comum do
mundo vem essa história mais comum do
brasil cá crianças nascendo sem os pais
ea minha mãe meu pai
isso é uma lástima que me criou o super
bem mas é uma lástima uma mulher assume
todas as responsabilidades de ser pai e
mãe e voy e enfim professora e tudo ao
mesmo tempo e é uma lástima para a
criança porque essa peça mais insegura e
acho que por algum tempo eu fui meio
agressivo no que eu falava o fazia
porque justamente o cientista de
segurança e por último é uma lástima
para o pai velho porque ele não sabe o
que ele perdeu
ele não sabe o que ele pede cada um cara
que abandona uma mulher grávida não sabe
o que está perdendo porque tem um filho
eu não sei como é ter um pai mas eu sei
como é ter um filho ea melhor coisa do
mundo
eu tenho duas filhas de seu acordo com o
me dizendo papai e é como se só tivesse
anulado pelo menos se sente quentinho cá
cada braço de uma criança de 3 anos se
economizar uma grana de psicólogo e
psiquiatra daqui a uns anos entender uma
vez sendo demandada com sua filha de 10
anos ela te contando histórias se sente
a pessoa mais sortuda do mundo kaká é
isso que esses caras que abandona
mulheres grávidas pedem uma série de
histórias cara de uma série de momentos
emocionantes divertidos e interessantes
cada vez mais eu vejo que pais mais
preocupados em ser mais presentes mais
carinhosos mais atenciosos e me parece
que a gente vive um site gaste um
momento em que os pais são mais
participativos cá mas querem essas
historinhas querem esse acordar perto
dos filhos quer levar eles na creche
querem curtir essas historinhas e eu
acho que a gente está chegando num ponto
em que a gente os melhores pais da
história porque ela nos anos 80 a 76 e
lembra como os pais uma filósofa está
ligado
você está brincando de lego na sala
chegava o pai ou mãe dizia sair correndo
todo mundo escondido que já estava
dormindo e não me diga que não sabe eram
a favor u
mas agora os nossos filhos nos acórdãos
chutando pai acorda gente olha que eu te
amo porque a gente ama isso a gente ama
ser pai
isso é incrível a gente tá sempre com
culpa meu som péssimo pai não sei se
escolher escola certa não sei se meu
filho se alimenta bem e se lembra como
era nos anos 80 a nossa mãe dava que
suco e bolacha maria de almoço eu estava
no banco de trás sem cinto hoje em dia
minha filha tem a cadeirinha 67 anos em
troca a cadeirinha rapidamente no dia
saca na cachoeira do fiat 147 lá atrás e
consegui isso com você também
também velho a gente os melhores a
melhor geração de pais está aqui mas
mais atenciosos prestam mais atenção e
que a nota essas histórias porque
comecei a notar essas histórias desde o
primeiro dia que me primeira filha
nasceu em 2005
as pessoas falavam é amor à primeira
vista é um momento mágico não é mano é
tipo allen é um bebê ainda na barriga da
sua mulher a sua mulher trânsito piada
que deixei de sangue as pessoas têm me
dito que vai se apaixonar pela primeira
vez assim com um amor à primeira vista
num ano é assustador
na primeira noite e minha mulher estava
dando de mamar de um lado bola do outro
lado nem de outro ela não aguentou mais
dormiu e era comigo eu chamei enfermeira
e disse pelo amor de deus me ajuda a
enfermeira disse não vem agora é com
você
isso já virou pilha é assim
esse momento era pra ser romântico
porque as pessoas que dizem que é
romântico e eu comecei a escrever sobre
isso quando não chegam antigo e da
primeira vez que as minhas filhas
começaram a falar e contar histórias
minha filha de 15 anos disse que é
casado eu falei porque casa tão cedo da
disputa também quer mandar em alguém
uma vez eu estava andando no shopping e
aí eu vou ser papai noel para ela a copa
não é o dela olhou pra mim o pai não
acompanhar um cara vestido de papai noel
ea minha segunda filha nasceu e é
completamente o contrário disso na
primeira super cerebral a segunda é
super festival acredita em tudo fada
coelho papai noel ela acredita em lobo
mau
às vezes digo pra eu sou o lobo mau e eu
digo não sou teu pai dela ai que bom
para o botafogo que agora há pouco e
essa vitória eu fui escrevendo porque é
incrível ser pai
e esses textos foram para a internet e
passar a alcançar mais de um milhão de
pessoas toda semana a gente transformou
se num livro é um livro chamado o papa é
pop ea gente lançou esse livro
eu esperava que fossem leite por 300
cópias e aparentemente o livro encontra
uma audiência nesses paz
que não abandona mulheres grávidas esses
pais que decidiram ser pais velho
decidiram participar da maior missão de
um ser humano que é criar uma outra
pessoa
esses pais lêem os livros se emocionam e
compartilham suas histórias já se esse é
o meu pagamento né
é isso que o que alimenta a minha alma
hoje pais que contam como é bom ser pai
e pais que abandonam seus filhos e
voltam a conversar com os filhos por
causa do livro e mães que criaram os
filhos sozinhas e que agora ouvir essas
histórias se identificou com a minha mãe
e compartilham e criam uma comunidade de
pessoas se ajudam na paternidade na
maternidade e na criação dessas pessoas
incríveis que mudar nossa vida
o livro chegou entre os mais vendidos do
brasil me levou pra cuba e eu fiquei
amiga brinca as teles que a coisa mais
bizarra do mundo pra mim
o livro já vendeu mais de 50 mil
exemplares
isso gera dinheiro e toda a grana
a gente vai devolver a crianças em
situação de fragilidade social a
crianças que precisam de grana as minhas
filhas também eu tenho meu trabalho as
minhas histórias consigo pagar o colégio
delas
esse dinheiro do livro é voltado para
crianças porque o meu pagamento são as
histórias que as pessoas compartilham as
minhas filhas não precisa de grana mais
e mais dinheiro eu não preciso mais
dinheiro
as minhas filhas e eu a gente precisa de
um mundo mais justo para elas é preciso
do mundo que as mulheres ganham das
coisas que os homens elas não sejam
sediadas de intimidade delas não vaze na
internet egípcio em um mundo onde não
acontece com as minhas filhas o que
aconteceu com a minha mãe velha que o
homem simplesmente abandona mulheres
grávidas e digão que vira e ontem estava
falando isso pra minha filha eu quero um
mundo em que seguem a mesma coisa que os
homens anita e ela me disse 'não pai eu
quero ganhar muito mais
as duas histórias que mais ouço nos
lançamentos do livro são primeira eu
também fui mãe solteira
a minha mãe me criou sozinho a história
mais comum no brasil
uma das histórias mais comuns do mundo
ea segunda está com mais o uso meu pai é
incrível eu amo meu pai
muito obrigado